[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it finally happened a brand-spanking-new
season in fortnight which has so much
new content to uncover if you're new
around these parts this is the series
where we look at all the map changes to
the world of font night from huge to
minut from obvious to trivial and
pointless sometimes but that's cool
to support this nonsense please slap
code atom arrow in the shop and now's a
great time to sub if you aren't already
pretty please this intro is too long
map changes season 3 let's do this
as so many people predicted the map was
indeed flooded lots of the former points
of interest are now left in ruin but
loads have popped up in their place
let's start with the former agency now
the authority now no heck no let's start
with something that really matters
Oh tingles hot watch I'm so happy to say
hot watch survived the flood and not
only that it has continued to evolve at
the end of last season two trucks
collided and this erection began to grow
right now it's looking like the hot
watch of old do you think epic will
change the og design or stick with it
we'll watch one day become an official
Pio i from what I can see right now in
game the removal trucks and other
workers are here with a crane clearing
the road above I'm just happy it
survived to be honest can I get a Hut
watch forever in the comments below
thank you very much anyway back to the
flood so the agency blew up and caused
all this water to change our island
forever
right now the authority has taken the
central spot and are ruling with an iron
fist with high-tech gadgets led by the
mechanic any theories on the
relationship between her and Midas
haven't found anything solid yet now all
the major landing spots are gone
this place will be a hot drop every time
and it's totally worth it for all the
vault goodies and speaking of the former
boss Pio eyes look at them now the shark
decimated the grotto sealed and flooded
the rig well the rig is sliced up into
numerous islands and the yacht has been
acquired by the water world people and
now sits in the most northern central
part of the map if like me you are
expecting all the Deadpool content to
completely vanish overnight we'll check
it out it's still here the statue the
artwork and even the sacred streaming
chair now are thrown to the greatest PG
streamer of all time do not bully people
sorry ninja remember when miles was
removed from service and began living at
the Box Factory well this bot had a huge
update today the Box Factory no longer
deals in boxes now it specializes in
robotics look at what he's putting
together now but once again I don't know
why so I put this to you what is going
on here
and if you're wondering why I still
believe this is musil's domain check out
the petrol station or gas station nearby
miles has a room set up in there with
all his favorite gear his story is not
over
and also remember those secret files on
agent Jonesy's desk links has more to
offer too so let's keep an eye on this
location also note there's a cafe here
now so we can watch over hot watch this
entire area is now called catty corner I
personally would have gone for something
like watch habitats just saying
moving north to retail row and another
subtle update can be spotted have you
noticed it there once was an office for
both ghost and shadow units but as we
all know shadow kicked butt last season
and to reflect that this Pio is a single
office for shadow our IP ghost and
speaking of ghosts have you visited the
four tiller it looks like we are a rebel
faction this season as the stronghold
has the og ego logos graffiti'd and
repurposed everywhere
the battle between ghost and Shadow has
only just begun
another example of this are the former
ghost strongholds which are now being
taken over by shadow as the ego logo is
lowered in defeat but an uprising must
begin soon
oh here's a great update remember the
old truckasaurus he's been around since
the dawn of the game since the very
first loop and last season he began to
proudly escape the sea well you may not
want to check back on this guy right now
during the flood event truckasaurus made
it close to land but not close enough
his body lays lifeless under the waves
just above the old docks he's flat out
how can we save this gentle giant after
checking on this hunka-hunka sunken mech
I looked for the iron man and I hate to
say this I can't find him anywhere I beg
you to help he sprang to life last
season and alas is no more I wonder if
he simply sat there and waited for the
waves to take him away but times anyway
every silver cloud no that's not right
anyway every cloud has a silver lining
English in England even English bro but
every cloud has a silver lining
whilst looking for Tony stank I found
this chap at the exact opposite side of
the island to truckasaurus a battle bot
made from trash and bathroom items is he
friend or foe what are the chances that
over the season he and truckasaurus
moved closer and closer until they
battled near the agency that would be
pretty epic right now above the agency I
mean the authority gonna have to get
used to that one there is a fishsticks
restaurant I originally thought this
must be from the old fishing spot but no
that is still there but I'll submerged
and mossy a cool Easter Egg to note here
check out the face on the sign a seaweed
mustache looks damn good so some of the
old Pio I survived Pleasant Park is now
held together by floats and barrels
thanks - no sweat insurance and Holly
hedges is doing very well if you think
about it and there's even softy springs
still here sort of the house with
demolition issues is now completely
reset and remember the chair thief from
last season the one who stole my
deceased golden throne to use in his own
house well it's gone and the floor is
fixed I knew it had to be here somewhere
so I looked for it and if you go over to
the right of Frenzy farm there is a no
sweat Insurance Building but this is not
an office this is a storage facility
look around in here and you'll see some
weird and wonderful things including
toilets for some reason and here it is
the golden chair still here still in one
piece and protected during the flood a
brilliant thing to add Thank You epic is
it just me or are these little tiny
things better than the huge hulking
things if you've been here before you
may know about our love of genomes organ
ohms one in particular is our Lord and
Savior Graham who has seen many things
during his time on the island right now
his radio shack has once again
completely reset but don't worry he's
completely fine - but his satellite dish
is now a pirate flag what could this be
telling us what is he planning like
usual keep an eye on grim there's a
couple of small details I think you
should note such as down at Camp Cod not
only is it under water and all the great
chapter one items are now submerged but
there's also this thing poking out of
the water with a chest robot on top come
on how cute is that little bugger they
can be spotted elsewhere on the map but
this one is extremely lucky and I have
it on good authority that if you open
this chest in game you will 101 percent
win the match if you don't believe me
check the comments below
chest bot equals free wins if you
believe that you believe anything
[Music]
back when Deadpool was revealed he was
seen on the old bridge well that old
bridge is gone he'd gone for good and
now there is a boat showroom of sorts
there instead the coolest thing to note
here is that you can jump in a boat and
drop straight into the water below and
it feels so damn badass up at the farm
it has survived it's it's not looking
great but it is still here a really cool
thing to note is the return of the old
wind turbines from Chapter one so maybe
they just got round to going through the
black hole and we could see more chapter
1 content coming soon but steamy stacks
it has survived quite well except for
the room with all the Kevin juice inside
it's now overflowing with seawater is
this the end of the experimentation or
maybe Kevin is now free again hit me up
with some of your predictions please
evolution has issues what will happen
next
oh and speaking of old updates returning
from the huge lake there was a house
which became a henchman lookout last
season remember once again that has
reverted to its original from four
months earlier and so of so many more
spots on the map it appears that this
season was created before the previous
season was finished which makes a lot of
sense and things aren't up to date as
we'd expect them to be but it creates
these really cool memories of frozen in
time like this but back to that house
look what is being built nearby a
racecourse of sorts maybe we should use
this for a meet-up and make terrible
videos together
going over to sweaty sounds and things
have changed yet again somehow the
location is kept together and also note
the incomplete building I have a feeling
that this is the season we get to see it
change other things to note are the
votes away from the core Islands the
core map these have lots of survival
items inside and one in the southwest
corner is fully converted into a dance
spot I'm thinking 100-person dance-off
who's in
and finally our spawn island sadly we've
lost the secret base underneath and now
the island is held together by rafts and
float tables it looks damn impressive
just like the film Waterworld oh one
more thing the bunker is still sealed
will this thing ever open I guess we
wait
[Music]
so there we have it a bunch of map
changes to kick off season 3 I'm sure
I've missed tons of things so hit me in
the comments with what you found and
I'll add it to the next episode on
screen are the leggings who've used code
a tomorrow last week thank you so much
for rockin my code I really appreciate
it and I'll be back in my Twitter DMS
all week to thank you personally much
appreciated
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]